Speaker 1: All right, this is a fascinating
story about how backwards the American right
wing currently is. I know many of you
have been following the controversy
with podcast host Joe Rogan. I've been on the
Rogan program two times. I've also spent the
last year calling out lots of the misinformation
that has been divulged on the Joe Rogan program.
Initially, the controversy with Joe Rogan was over
COVID disinformation, including multiple guests
making outrageous claims about vaccines and COVID,
which I couldn't possibly list now. But it led to
numerous musical artists, including Neil Young
and Joni Mitchell and others to pull their music
from Spotify. And it led to Joe Rogan putting out
a statement about the COVID misinformation, saying
I'm not trying to spread disinformation. I'm not
trying to be controversial, and I'm going to make
an effort to have more people on with what we
might consider sort of like the mainline medical
science views and some people felt the apology
was forced. Some people felt the Apollo apology
was disingenuous. Some people liked it, etc.
Shortly after the Kova disinformation controversy,
a compilation video of Rogan using the N-word
on his show from the last decade plus came out,
and it was a whole new controversy, including the
artist India.Arie saying, I'm pulling my music
from Spotify and Rogen doing another apology video
saying, Listen, when I watch this stuff, it's not
good. I recognize it's not good and I didn't have
racist intent and OK, he did another apology. Some
people didn't like the apology. Some people like
the apology. Others said This is the right thing
to say. Others said this is the wrong thing to
say. The content of it is not actually at issue
here. What is fascinating is that the right is
now turning on Rogen because he apologized because
he apologized. Early on in this controversy,
the right were the defenders of Rogen saying
It's great that he's putting out their alternative
views about COVID and vaccines, even if they're
completely not based, in fact. This is a guy who,
you know, don't cancel the race. The use of the
N-word is fine. It's all fine. Rogan's great,
great great. Take 100 million bucks to come to
rumble. We learned yesterday all this different
stuff, but now that Rogen has apologized and I'll
be honest, I think the apologies are sincere.
It doesn't mean anything in particular about
Rogan's intent. When he said the stuff, I have no
idea. But I do think his apologies are sincere,
at least as far as he feels today. Now the
right is turning on Rogen first and foremost,
Donald Trump putting out a statement saying
Joe Rogan is an interesting and popular guy,
but he's got to stop apologizing to the fake
news and radical left maniacs and lunatics. How
many ways can you say you're sorry, Joe? Just go
about what you do so well and don't let him make
you look weak and frightened. That's not you.
And it never will be. So Trump not pleased with
the apologies, but still sort of deferential to
Rogen. But then all sorts of conservative media
and elected officials saying Rogen is wrong
to apologize. Let's look first at a clip of
Florida Gov. Ron DeSantis saying No,
no, no, no, no. The apology is bad.
Speaker 2: Mob will come after people, and they're
targeting Rogen because he's threatening to upset
the apple cart on some of the things that they're
holding dear. And with COVID, he's just bringing
opposing views. He's letting people decide.
They say he's against vax. I've not lost a show,
but then I read. He specifically advocated for
people with co-morbidities and elderly to get
vaccinated, and so a lot of this is just
either he's got a huge audience. I think
a lot of the legacy outlets and I think the left
fear the fact that he can reach so many people
and so they're out to destroy him. But now the
Speaker 1: funny thing is, Rogan's audience,
by most estimates, is down 50 percent since he
moved to Spotify. So this fear about the audience,
it's kind of a weird thing. But OK, DeSantis says
the apology was wrong, and Trump says the apology
was wrong. But then look at what is happening
on other conservative media outlets. Here is
Stephen Crowder weighing in on the apology stuff.
Speaker 2: I'm not going to lie. I was upset. Yes,
I was angry with no with Joe as well, and I'll
explain to you. I am more angry, of course,
with the people who've tried to. Yeah, I hate to
use the term cancel culture, but the people who
have tried to destroy his life and his livelihood.
Now Joe Rogan is bigger than them. So good for him
it shouldn't affect him. I hope he understands
the power that he has. Unfortunately, he's caved
a little bit, and I just that makes it harder for
everybody else, and I have a lot of respect for
Joe. I think he's a good guy. I've spent some time
with him. So it's always hard for me, just full
disclosure to be objective when I know somebody.
Speaker 1: So anyway, there Steven Crowder,
Steven Crowder says Joe Rogan caved. Then we go
next to Steve Bannon. Trump propagandist Steve
Bannon also not pleased. Let's listen to him.
Speaker 2: OK. Welcome here in the war room,
it's Monday, seven February, the year of Our
Lord 2022. Now, with the closing in of almost 140
million downloads on the podcast, I
just want to add we did that without
Spotify, and we did that without groveling
to Spotify. Oh, more on Spotify in the weeks,
days and weeks ahead. But it is. It is amazing
a note to Joe Rogan. The more you grovel,
the more episodes are going to take down, the more
Speaker 1: Joe Rogan being admonished by Steve
Bannon for groveling. And then we also have Glenn
Beck. Glenn Beck doesn't like what Rogan has done.
And I think the audio comes in him.
Speaker 2: First of all, Joe,
never apologize, and I don't mean it like never
apologize when you've done something that you find
offensive or wrong. You should always apologize
when you have done something that you're ashamed
of. So apology accepted. Apology warranted?
Perhaps. Perhaps. Maybe if you were using it
in context, I don't think so. But maybe should
Joe Biden apologize for what he said in that?
I don't. I mean, I don't think so. No, I don't.
He was quoting someone. That's that's I am giving.
I don't know every word that Joe Rogan has said on
the podcast. So maybe he has thrown it out there.
You know, 12 years ago without context,
you know what I mean? I don't know.
So I'm giving him the benefit of the doubt and
saying, you know, if that was what happened,
then you should apologize. But not
to these people, not to these people.
If you really did hurt and offend people
with it. Your audience would have told you
that you wouldn't be as successful as you are now.
Speaker 1: This is just it's just kind of weird.
It's a weird argument that Glenn Beck makes
because he wasn't as well known at the time
that he did the segments that became part of that
compilation. So I don't you know the question. The
better question would be if you said that stuff
now, what would be the reaction from your much
bigger audience? And I think it's very clear that
much of the current audience would be offended. So
anyway, the point here is what has gotten the
right to now say Joe, you're groveling Joe, you're
doing. The wrong thing is that he has apologized,
an apology that I know many in my audience think
is completely insincere. You know, I've said this
idea that that an apology is not warranted here
seems bizarre to me. And of course, if you
believe that he was forced by Spotify to
apologize in order to keep his show. That would be
a reason to think the apology is is disingenuous,
but it doesn't appear to be the case. Spotify
has said We're keeping Rogan. We've pulled some
episodes because of some of the content,
but we like Rogen. We're keeping Rogen,
and it is amazing how what has triggered the right
is, you know, a dozen uses of the N-word. No,
they're fine with that. Total out and out
COVID disinformation from guests that Rogen
doesn't challenge. They say, no, he's giving
alternate views. That's that's totally fine.
The apology has catalyzed an coalesced Trump.
DeSantis. Steven Crowder, Stephen Bannon, Glenn
Beck and others who I'm not playing today to say
now Rogen is doing the wrong thing. The apology
is now the wrong thing. These people are truly
incredible, and it just reminds us. These are not
good counterparts to any kind of real discussions
about solving problems on the planet that affect
humans and moving forward in a productive
way. They're just not good faith actors.